la première chose qui frappe ici c'est
la foule il y à 100 fois plus de
personnes kilomètres carrés par rapport
au canada trois fois plus qu'en chine il
faut accepter d'être touchée d'être
bousculé l'un venu dans un des pays les
plus tordus mans
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
fait de huit millions de personnes
prennent le train chaque jour à mumbai
c'est comme si tous les québécois se
rendait dans les gares au même moment le
concept de files d'attentes juste pas
vraiment en inde
ce genre de wagons est prévu pour 200
personnes mais ils peuvent être jusqu'à
500 à s'entasser à l'intérieur
l'ex comptable qui a une heure et demie
de trajet chaque matin a trouvé une
façon originale d'avoir de la place
assise dans le travail qu'avait formé
une session à gogo danseuse
les femmes aussi recherche une certaine
forme de confort dans le wagon qu'il
aurait réservé un chiffre hallucinant
chaque jour à mumbai une dizaine de
personnes décèdent sur les rails
soit parce qu'ils ont été heurtés par un
train en traversant ou alors parce
qu'ils sont carrément tombé du wagon
vous pensez que le trafic des trains
c'est ce qu'il ya de pire ici et bien
non il y en a un qui prend encore plus
de temps et qui a encore plus dangereux
le trafic automobile
regarder un petit peu
non
[Musique]
attendez
gazzard avoir la liberté à la durée des
points le gallia réalisateur aux acteurs
du secteur il y aurait 300 milles riccio
les tuk tuk comme celui là dans tout mon
bail et c'est sans compter les dizaines
de milliers de taxis et les automobiles
de plus en plus nombreuses à mesure que
la classe moyenne est capable de s'en
payer
le résultat c'est un trafic quasi
permanent dans cette ville
oui